The Luxembourg Government is creating legislation
and providing $220 million dollars in incentives
for companies to begin mining asteroids.
And Snotbot is a drone from DJI that is helping
researchers study whales by safely and easily
collecting their snot.
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
GauntLev is a levitation glove. Bristol Interaction
Group developed the gauntlet that uses acoustic
levitation to allow a user to handle fragile
or dangerous materials without touching them.
They’ve also developed other acoustic levitation
manipulation tools including the sonic screwdriver
and ultra tongs. Acoustic Levitation was first
mentioned in Mind Blow #50 back in September
2012 as a static system. These new tools allow
for basic maneuvers and human controlling
of levitating objects - representing a major
leap forward for the technology. Also it just
looks awesome.
Keeping busy in Bristol researchers are developing
a shape changing handheld device. Cubimorph
uses turntable hinges on cubes that can accommodate
six touchscreen each, allowing for a variety
of programmable shapes to provide modular
interactivity. The successful proof of concept
could lead to mobile phones transforming into
game controllers as the materials and designs
get smaller, cheaper and sturdier.
If you’ve ever wanted to hear the Milky
Way then thank an asteroseismologist. Astrophysicists
from the University of Birmingham measure
tiny changes in the brightness of stars to
determine their age and mass - they recently
detected oscillations in the oldest known
cluster of stars in our galaxy at 13 billion
years old. Here’s what they sound like.
Let’s rock.
It turns out snails use just two brain cells
to make decisions. For example, One neuron
encodes the presence of food and another one
gauges the snail’s motivational state - so
there’s food and I’m hungry leads to let’s
eat. The study can lead to building new decision-making
systems based on only two neurons - more specifically
robot brains.
Exoskin is a shape-changing material that
creates tangible interfaces with tactile feedback.
Developed by the MIT Media Lab the material
consists of silicone triangles on flexible
bladders that allow it to change texture.
Their first proposed use for this would be
a steering wheel that integrates GPS navigation
directions naturally - so you can actually
feel where you need to go. And ultimately
their plan is to break the divide of human-computer
interaction allowing people to physically
interact with digital systems.
Solar Impulse 2 is a single-seater zero fuel
airplane which recently landed safely in New
York City after a trip across the Pacific
Ocean and will next cross the Atlantic. It
uses SunPower solar cells to collect energy
for charging lithium batteries during morning
flights at altitudes up to 28,000 feet (8,534.4
m). At night, it glides to lower altitudes
and uses the battery power until sunrise.
They hope eventually it could someday provide
a clean, renewable method of transportation.
Mind Blow #82 in May 2014 featured Wi-Fi clothes.
Along with Wi-Fi, The BB suit concept featured
GPS and Bluetooth to turn your clothes into
an mp3 player. Well today there's a company
called Machina that's making wearable technology
including a jacket that plays music in the
hood using bluetooth connected to your smart
phone and a new virtual reality jacket. The
Out of Body Experience jacket is embedded
with sensors that allow the movement of your
body to effect VR. Turning the user into an
immersive controller by wearing a normal-looking
jacket instead of some weird suit.
Finally, thanks to a new algorithm, humanoid
robot Atlas can now detect partial footholds
and autonomously adjust itself to stay balanced.
I’m gonna leave you with a brain interface
for controlling robot swarms and as always
- thanks for watching.
Hello? Hello is this the office? I can't hear
much of anything. Sounds like someone crying.
Oh but my dear you mustn't be so critical.
Of course it sounds strange at first, the
advertisement says it will.
Well, I don't think much of it. No one will
ever use it!
You mark my words, dear. The time will come
when we will all use it! Well, we may even
talk with distant cities.
With distant cities. Oh, John, you're such
a dreamer!